plongez dans une actualité quasi
exclusivement consacrée à la pandémie de
kobe 19 quelle ne fut pas notre surprise
en tombant sur cet article du guardian
blackrock va conseiller l'union
européenne sur les règles
environnementales pour les banques
concrètement la multinationale
américaine sera chargé d'étudier comment
l'union européenne pourrait être intégré
au mieux les facteurs environnementaux
et sociaux dans sa supervision des
banques
c'est en fait la branche conseil de
l'entreprise qui a remporté cet appel
d'offres au nez et à la barbe de huit
autres concurrents un contrat avec la
commission européenne qui rapportera 550
mille euros à la firme mais ce n'est pas
ce qui inquiète le plus le plus étonnant
pour beaucoup c'est surtout que
blackrock n'était absolument pas un
modèle de vertu en ce qui concerne le
développement durable parmi les
milliards de dollars d'actifs qu'elle
gère à travers le monde
blackrock est un des plus grands
investisseurs mondiaux au sein des
entreprises pétrolières et possède des
parts importantes dans l'industrie des
énergies fossiles se pose donc la
question d'une forme de conflit
d'intérêts blackrock prendra-t-elle le
risque de livrer des recommandations
ayant un impact direct sur ses
investissements dans des groupes ne
respectant pas les règles
environnementales sur twitter élus et
ong rivalisent d'imagination pour tenter
des comparaisons il ya par exemple
greenpeace qui ironise et pourquoi pas
le capitaine du titanic chargés de la
sûreté maritime ou encore manon aubry
qui écrit on attend avec impatience
totale missionné pour arrêter le pétrole
monsanto pour mettre fin aux pesticides
et les îles caïmans pour lutter contre
l'évasion fiscale
raphaël prado porte-parole de
l'organisation attac il va lui aussi de
sa comparaison ironique
un peu comme si on demandait aux époux
balkany et d'écrire un rapport sur
comment lutter contre la fraude fiscale
ce ne s'est pas crédible on peut se
demander quand même comment la
commission européenne a pu le proposer à
blackrock décrit un rapport qui va
réfléchir à comment à prendre en compte
les facteurs environnementaux dans la
supervision des banques alors que
blackrock c'est un des plus gros
investisseur mondial dans le pétrole
dans les énergies fossiles mais aussi
dans les banques
je rappelle que
blackrock détient des actions dans
beaucoup d'entreprises et
particulièrement dans les entreprises
sur lesquelles maintenant elle va écrire
des conseils pour la commission
européenne donc un risque de conflit
d'intérêts qui est assez important de
son côté blackrock a beau affirmer que
sa branche conseil est différente de sa
branche gestionnaire d'actifs les
soupçons sont tenaces surtout que le
guardian révèle contre 2015 et 2019
la multinationale s'est opposé ou
abstenu sur 82 % des résolutions
concernant le climat dans les
entreprises dont elle possède des parts
de quoi renforcer l'inquiétude des plus
sceptiques que la vaste campagne de
greenwashing lancée par le géant de la
finance n'a pas convaincu en janvier
blackrock a annoncé se désengager des
entreprises tirant plus de 25 % de leurs
revenus du charbon surtout que blackrock
était déjà dans le viseur en france d'un
certain nombre de militants des actions
ont été menées ces derniers mois au
siège français de la société visée pour
ses décisions anti écologique mais aussi
pour son lobbying en faveur de la
réforme des retraites menée par le
gouvernement
une image écornée dans l'opinion qui a
fait de blackrock un symbole dont le nom
arbore désormais fréquemment les
pancartes des manifestants
et ce n'est pas cette collaboration avec
bruxelles qui devrait arranger les
choses